[Music]
he's Jameis Winston he's the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers quarterback they beat the
Falcons once and then they lost at home
to the Falcons so coming off a nine and
seven season but we are curious about a
younger quarterback watching Tom Brady
last night Jameis Winston joining us now
where did you watch the game last night
I watched it from my couch in my living
room all by yourself with my girlfriend
my dog and a couple friends all right
explain to us what you're seeing as an
NFL quarterback watching what Brady does
in the fourth quarter I'm just saying a
winner be a winner it's it's so unreal
how he just always under way to win I
mean just epitome of what a true
quarterback is what you're trying to you
know we look at this and there was maybe
some doubt about is he the greatest
quarterback of all time should there be
any doubt whatsoever even prior to last
night well it's me my whole life I've
got a chance to watch peyton and Brady
growing up and those those who
quarterbacks are truly amazing first of
all pain with just how his pregame I
mean pre-slap awarenesses and embraer
was just how efficient and consistent he
has been over the years to me and my
lifetime he is the greatest quarterback
ever but to be down that many points
what do you say to your kid you were
down big in the national title game when
you guys want right and then you have to
kind of say to your teammates hey or
what do you say well well the
expectation still has to be there that
you're going win you know when you're
down I get quarterback base they don't
never think they're losing the game like
you can't did no one no good quarterback
process is that hey we're about to lose
the game the only thing we're thinking
okay what can we do to help us you know
just keeps going and scoring and move
the ball get first downs and ultimately
come back you know how can we I can eat
the crease the deficit and the lead out
central victory
when did you think the Patriots were
going to win I knew the Patriots were
going to win when it was like three
minutes and 40 seconds and Tom had to
drive it down I able to leave the
2-minute drill like it was three minutes
and 40 seconds you just knew he was
going to drive it down and today we're
gonna score and then the two-point
conversion I was like oh my god like
that's a smoke screen and they get in
for a two-point conversion so it was
over there did you meet Tom Brady have
you met him I've never met her no sir
what would you say i would say thank you
for what you've done temporary what I
said any quarter better that I me thank
you for for what you've done for my game
it's an honor to meet you and that's all
I when I'm going to really say much in
that situation he'd probably be want a
few people i'll be around that I just
say hey how you doing and just not be
able to talk it wouldn't be one of those
can I get an autograph for a picture oh
yeah it would be one of those things
that I would have to like planning out
me mean Tom Brady like when I went to
pay many many camp I had to plan out
what questions I was gonna act because I
knew been in the room wit for Eli
obtained how I was gonna kind of be
quiet and that's not my nature how old
were you when you met Peyton I was I was
19 I'm buried ok right but you planted
at like you kind of stalked Peyton to
say I'm gonna find it the best time to
say something to him well no we we uh we
got a chance to you know just hang
around them and uh I guess they had like
an event that we were able to go to that
Prescott was actually that's what I
first met him as well and I've had the
you know have some good and see you Oh
what am I gonna say to painting Eli but
now I'm cool now that I met him it's
easy for me to talk to them James's when
she to the buccaneers joining a stand
Patrick show what's it like you saw
Brady get hit a lot I mean he got sacked
this Atlanta was was putting the body on
him just about every time
what's that like knowing when you throw
you're going to get hit well that's
that's one thing I was affected by Tom
Brady's she's don't standing that make
the throw you know that's he is like I
said the epitome of the quarterback
position he's not gonna get route
rattled he's always gonna be calm he's
gonna execute to play and what I seen
him get hit I was like man you know when
you hit a quarter belt like that it
doesn't you know doesn't offend the
harder it makes him you know want to be
more precise and makes them work on his
timing way more so this is tough to be
bigger hi I know the Falcons are in your
division were you rooting for the
Falcons to win because the renovation I
was ruled it forward the vote shakes
Tremont I wanted him to get a super bowl
especially him being a teammate of my at
Florida State so I was going to him in
our division with two back-to-back years
so that's obviously signing you know it
gets my blood pumping cuz I'm glad I'm
next so I was always excited to see them
there and matt wright had an amazing
year but i was grupo de vache freeman i
was looking for a great game and boy did
we not kidding give me the guy that you
met in Houston that you thought was
great or different or you were nervous
to meet whatever the experience was was
there one former player ah I actually
got a chance to chat with a few Sam's a
full a little bit at the NFL house it
was actually good to to really have a
conversation with him without it being a
production mean I'm having to come and
say one of my games but just in his
perspective on things and actually him
about you know the process of being in
the Super Bowl was it was pretty fun but
my ultimate uh my sleeper pick was a
male blunt I got a chance to just some
time with mel blount and his family it
was my first time ever me me and him you
know you had
yeah this cowboy hat on i told them that
i don't think i ever gets it up to the
level well I'm good enough to wear a
cowboy hat and play crush you know
imagine being a defensive back o gently
mean that's a big dude okay that's a
huge that's a huge huge man and also and
the way the way the game is evolving now
we're starting to see you no more
offenders like them but you guys should
you did a lot there I know make-a-wish
Foundation Defensive Rookie of the Year
award you handed that out so you had to
get a busy weekend there what would
still down uh you know I think the the
most fun time I had was definitely get a
chance to go to the NFL experience and
spent time with the make-a-wish
foundation I wish you could have been
there man it was it was amazing you know
you know kids engaged and playing
football me at one point I had to make a
wish foundation kids actually playing
one-on-one you know I was getting them
blown around give them compete get them
engaged and that's what it's all about
you know those kids they don't they
don't wake up in the morning and think
hey I got to go play football with these
NFL players and have a blast but they
did and some that they're gonna remember
forever and just like me just like bill
meeting me it's kind of neat watching
the Super Bowl watching Tom Brady do
what he does do what he does you know
when it five super bowls in my lifetime
watching where five super bowls in my
lifetime it's amazing it's a real to me
and I just love it well congrats on your
second season there and maybe it's a
sign maybe your the next team up in the
NFC sound so thank you for joining us
Jameis enjoy the offseason Thank you
Thank You mr. pressure a real appreciate
you Jameis Winston Buccaneers
quarterback watching that game and at
least through his eyes I've just curious
what a young quarterback would think
watching Brady win five super bowls to
go to seven Super Bowls and of course he
referred to me as mr. Patrick the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
I